going back to this rolling stone gig
you're doing now you advised
men going down on women not gross you
need to return the favor
women have orgasms and you need to find
the fun button
sex advice true yes absolutely look for
it you look for it you go for it
you look for that little sucker and then
pay attention to it
tell me where to find that thing because
i seem to miss follow the legs
follow the legs it'll lead you right to
it
listen you're an expert what i'm not
going to argue with you about sex
you're kidding and then you even advised
men
who are impotent you said you may not
die tomorrow but you've got today
impotence not the end of the world just
the end of sex
i think that's a healthy message i think
that you're saying well
what you're hearing is an 80 year old
man truck
we don't have any choice is that a
goddamn choice it's a
it's a absolutely terrible thing when
your
wiener no longer works believe me but
you have to
work it out and and get used to the idea
and truthfully men what
the really valuable thing about my
relationship with my wife
was always the the heart it was always
the lie she's a wonderful woman
you know i had more than my chairman i
think we can agree on that
you certainly don't know um so i'm i'm
not worried about it i
i'm i'm kind of relaxed into the
situation and i'm okay
whenever i talk about you to anybody i
always said you know david with that
mustache that mustache must have some
stories to tell uh
oh
shut up myself